so think about any 14 year old going to
high school what are some things you
think a 14 to an 18 year old in high
school
should be taught so they're ready for
the real world is it chemistry
is it biology is it physics when's the
last time you use those three things
unless if that's the industry you're
part of
today i'm going to talk to you about 15
things that school won't teach you
[Music]
so imagine the school's got four years
right to inject a certain mindset in you
so when you leave high school you can
win and excel in life what are some
things you would teach
this would be the 15 things i would
teach so number one would be how to sell
now why how to sell because i believe
everything you do in life has to do with
selling and persuading
the woman you date the job you get the
interview when you have to persuade your
boss to give you a job or
asking for a promotion or wanting to get
a scholarship all of that have to do
with selling so imagine if there's a
course
where kids go to all year long and they
learn how to sell
back and forth sell me this sell me that
how would you sell this how would you
sell that how would you sell real estate
how
imagine there's a training for that at
14 years old what life would look like a
14 year old to learn
how to sell number two is taxes how
taxes work now why would we teach taxes
because you got to show taxes to show
here's
who pays the fewest amount of taxes
entrepreneurs why because they create
jobs so they have more write-offs
this is where you pay the most this is
where you pay the lease this is what you
have to pay no matter
what you got federal you got state you
got you know
local level you got you know different
kind of health taxes all the
all of these taxes and then state taxes
the state's lower that stays slower
it's preparing the kid to say huh when
i'm 18 years old
if i go to school i wouldn't mind going
to that state i wouldn't mind going to
the state or if i run for what if i love
this place i don't want to leave this
place
i wouldn't mind trying to contribute to
figure out a way to improve the taxes
if i want to get a career going it's
better for me to make this kind of money
there's no surprises i'm paying
taxes and a lot of kids in high school
get their first job so they're gonna pay
taxes anyways so imagine if they're
gonna learn how taxes work number three
how to lead why how to lead in every
situation a kid is involved in there's
gonna be an opportunity to lead
in a fight in a position where somebody
is about to backstab another backstop of
another person
in a position where someone's about to
do drugs someone's about to sell drugs
some of anything that happens where
there's a bad situation imagine if every
kid is saying
listen the world needs more
leaders you give examples of 50 leaders
here's the trials they have here's the
challenges they faced here's what they
had the options the choices they had
here's how they overcame it and guess
what history looks at them in this
way this is what this person was
thinking about 19 qualities of
leadership
you give them four or five books to read
during that semes
semester or year it is and you study
certain personalities
leadership and everything they do people
gonna be learning how to lead or needing
to learn how to lead number four
how money works whether you like it or
not most kids come out of high school
right off the bat the first thing they
get is a what a credit card
and they max it out somebody like me
forty nine thousand dollars in debt
and then i have to try to pay this off
it takes me years to pay it off gives me
a setback what if somebody would have
taught me about credit cards
nobody sat me down teaching my credit
cards and you know saying hey here's
what you got to look at interest rates
is this here's how this works here's how
this credit card works
here's how mutual fund works of course
there's some of that being taught in
school right now
but i'm not not at those levels or if
you get lucky and have a great teacher
if you got an average teacher they're
not teaching you this stuff number five
how to negotiate
different than how to sell is how to
negotiate i teach my kids very early on
how to negotiate
i'll go in there and i'll say hey uh dad
can i watch a movie tonight i said why
why do you deserve to watch a movie
well earlier you asked me to do this
yesterday i did this
and quite frankly my grades have come up
am i making my shots better
and the other day i did this and i think
i deserve a watching movie today
okay fine you make sense fair enough
you're able to watch a movie everything
becomes a negotiation so they're
learning from a young age
on how to negotiate because i know for
the rest of their lives
they're gonna have to negotiate so kids
can benefit a lot from negotiation
number six
how to start a business obviously this
is america or whatever country you're
watching this from but in america
you know we believe in free enterprise
capitalistic society which means
the benefit goes to the business owner
right now today the news came out that
elon musk is officially richest man in
the world he just passed the bezos
they're two entrepreneurs and if you
turn on the tv you watch new news you
read an article
you go on social you're gonna see the
two faces of elon musk with tesla
and jeff bezos with amazon what if we
took a
semester to teach kids and inspire them
hey listen i don't know if this is for
you or not entrepreneurship or not but
if you were to ever start a business
here's what to think about what if every
high school asked every kid
to start a business and go out there and
make five hundred dollars to get an
a you know if you make five hundred
dollars it's a b you know
thousand dollars it's an a two hundred
fifty dollars what if we ran a class
like that
that here's a product go sell it come
back see what you can do and there's got
to be a way where you measure it
where it doesn't just say kid's name is
bobby jones and everything everybody
that bought every product from bobby
jones senior bobby jones this
other people have to go sell to other
people what if a course was set up
for people to work together as a team
and start a business together what if
that happened what if that's how they
were judged what if that's how they got
their grades
imagine the possibilities of a kid that
did that number seven
how to think for yourself and the reason
why i think it's how to think for
yourself
is peer pressure you're gonna go through
a lot of peer pressure hey
smoke this drink this you know sniff
this
do this take this take that out take
your pants
everything is peer pressure you know
everything i say let's go and take this
that no one's gonna know no one's gonna
know no one's gonna know
what if we teach you how to think for
yourself yeah that's what they're doing
but here's where you got to learn how to
think for yourself and this goes with
how to lead
what if you start saying this up here's
what you're going to be facing over the
next
two four years as you're going to high
school here's what's going to happen to
you
someone's going to offer you drugs
someone's gonna offer you how to sell
them
someone's gonna offer you this someone's
gonna offer you this someone's gonna
offer you this
and then you open it up so johnny how do
you handle this so guys how would you
handle this and you let them talk
and one percent jokes if somebody
offered me something smoke i said
give me a hit you already know that
kid's probably smoking or joking you're
learning about kids right what they're
doing
but you're educating them how to handle
the pressure that they're going to be
dealing with
i was 25 26 years old a director of
psychology for glendale high school
sandra bayes invited me to work with a
class it was five classes that i went
through
and i have the videos till today and i
sat with them
for six month period every week i would
go to them and one of the things we
would talk about
was tell me your biggest peer pressure
what's the biggest thing you deal with
you would be amazed what these 14
15 16 year old kids who they gave me the
worst the troubled kids where they had
the whole
stuff on their ankles 14 year old girl
that's pregnant they gave me the worst
at
the most troubled teenagers at 14 15 16
i had them saying
see what you can do with the director of
psychology that sat there with me the
entire time as a way of me being held
accountable
we went through it you would be amazed
how much pressure these kids have today
more than when i went through it 26 16
years ago when i was sitting down with
these kids
way more than ever before but we're not
talking about just kind of like well
yeah it's okay let them use the phones
let them go through this stuff they
don't want
they don't talk about it unless somebody
creates a safe place for them to be
willing to talk about number eight how
to process
issues a problem-solving formula hey
here when this happens in your life use
this system so johnny
let's just say you're in a situation
where this breaks out or something like
this happens
how do you use this formula for
processing issues in this scenario
uh number one i would do this okay
number two i would oh i would do this
okay why don't you
you know crowdsource it with your peers
what would you guys do together in group
number a or group number d
i would probably yeah yeah we would do
this i was perfect
what would you guys oh no we would do
this great so what is the most optimum
you know situation on how to solve this
problem and process issues
then we come out with it great team b
you get 50 points
what if that was that kind of an
environment and a high school be so much
fun to be thinking about
so what do you think about what happened
yesterday an election hey what do you
think what happened
yesterday with the capitol hill you know
how do you think those people that were
there what do you think the fbi should
be doing
what do you think happening with sports
what do you think is going on with
politics what do you think what's going
on with this
what do you think what happened with the
economy and you open it up how can we
solve that problem
how would you solve the problem taxes
how would you solve the problem of
homelessness in california
how would you do it what would be the
right way how is can you imagine if
these kids are thinking about the stuff
from 14 to 18 years old not later on
from 14 to 18
let's have a system for solving problems
number nine how to make millions why not
why not have a you know have a make
million now watch this imagine if a
school
high school if you got four thousand
kids that means you got eight thousand
four to eight thousand parents right mom
and dad
if you got four thousand kids eight
thousand parents odds are there are some
parents that are successful
now what if you incentivize the parents
to come in
to say they're going to give you eight
hours per year what if you got
10 parents that agree 20 people that
agree what if you got 40 people that
agree
40 times 8 hours over a year that's 320
hours
kids are going through the class and
each of them teaches their own
method of how they run a business and
how they make millions how did you do it
well here's you know one of the ways to
do it we got involved in this business
you ever seen that guy on
i think it's like a tick tock where he
goes around saying hey you got a nice
car how'd you make your money
hey you got a nice guy how do you make
you know that one guy don't know the
guys but i see it on instagram
how'd you make your money how'd you make
your money today is gonna be
john doe's father is here and he runs a
dry cleaning business
everybody john father runs a very
successful business
business please give it up for mr jones
and mr dole
hi everybody great so let me kind of
give you an idea i got into the
dry cleaning business i got out of
school i started working out dry
cleaning all of a sudden the owner
wanted to sell me a location i bought it
i became a general manager
about 20 into it and now i have nine of
them and these nine locations bring us
this many we have 43 employees
and here's what worked for us when it
comes down to business so what i would
tell you is before thinking about going
through a business
is a 10-step process what if these kids
are learning how to make millions at
that age
now here's what's going to happen out of
30 kids in a classroom guess what
half of them are not going to pay any
attention the other half is going to be
like
huh it's pretty interesting i like it
this is something i'd want to do i would
have been making millions dry cleaning
not for me next father i run real estate
i like this
i don't like real estate next guy i run
a dealership really how do i get into
the dealership next one
i'm a dentist i got six dentists that
work for me but their mind is going and
saying this is who i'm connected with
and they can ask questions right
it's different than watching content
here because you can't ask me questions
but you can ask me questions if i'm in a
classroom and i'm touching you we're
going through it together and we're
speaking about it number 10
how to marry and how to date it's a big
topic it's something that a lot of
people struggle with no one gives you a
manual to it
no one tells you how to date no one
tells you what to look for first thing
you look for when you're dating what was
the first thing you looked for when you
did you're like oh my gosh
look at her you know she looks good and
you got hey
hey can you and then boom you start
dating you're holding hands then you
kissed and you know what then the third
base
like oh my god you have no clue what
you're going through there's not a
manual most boys don't
don't talk to their mom and dad or
daughters don't talk to their parents
but what if there's a safe place
guys when you're dating how should you
date what do you think you should do
when you're dating
what do you look for who's looking for
this what's the wrong person to did why
wouldn't you is everybody good for you
is somebody good for everybody
when should you get married what's a
good age to get married what if you ask
these kids these questions and they
start talking
and they're saying well i don't mean
marriage you screw marriage
really tell me why you don't want to get
married why don't you want to get
married okay that makes sense how about
who wants to get married who doesn't
want to get married
and you bring a people parents that
volunteer and get them involved so they
see what their kids are doing
here's what workforce we've been married
for 28 years here's what worked for me i
made married for 22 years
i'm on my second marriage first one
didn't work yeah second me and my wife
been together for 15 years let me tell
you what mistakes i made in the first
one
let me tell you what i did right on the
second one oh wow it's pretty open
interesting conversation i'm learning
from jackie's father that was great
how to marry and how to date number 11.
number 11 is how to vote
yeah obviously nowadays when you think
about how to vote if you say the wrong
name god forbid something is going to
happen to you so i voted for trump i
voted for buy and i voted for this
but actually how do you vote so why is
your voice matter
locally right statewide national you
know
president governor congressman senate
mayor why why does your vote matter
that's really my vote count i'm only one
person i'm going to be 18 years old no
one cares about my voice
yes so you give the teacher the history
of voting here's what's happened here's
what's worked
here's the power you have you can voice
your opinion these are other countries
that don't have the right that we have
you give them the how to vote number 12
how to parent
why do you teach kids early on how to
parent because it's a thing that they
can start thinking about right now very
early on they can say well this is what
i'm going to be doing for parents and
grow when i'm raising my own kids
but it's a very important topic early
number 13 conflict resolution because
you're going to be facing
conflicts and everything you do date
family you know peers
friends teachers professors coaches the
teammates on the sports team
no matter what what if they took one
full year on conflict resolution and the
kids learn how to handle conflict
resolution
do you know what would happen if they're
learning this if they're learning how to
process issues
if they're learning how to lead put them
all together you develop and future
leaders of this country
number 14 and number 14 we got objective
view on politics
how would you do this very simple a very
confident republican
who doesn't judge the opposing side and
a very confident
democrat who doesn't judge the opposing
side and a very confident independent
you bring him up and you let him debate
you let him hash it out and you let the
kids listen to it and they make a
decision for themselves
it's not for me it's for me great i like
it i don't like it
and you know i was talking to somebody
that said in in
oxford university in india uh that they
went to school one of the things that
they did
is the fact that you learn debate but
the first thing about debating your
position of your topic
step number one is you got to learn the
other person's position on their topics
before you can debate your position what
if we
taught them you know 15 basic
rules on debating respect the other
person's opinion not everyone's going to
agree with you
this isn't about you being right 100
percent of the time what if we taught
some of that stuff you think we'd be
fighting with the way we are right now
not falling for all the division that's
taking place around
the country with media we wouldn't fall
for that and last but not least which is
very important
is how to deal with failure and how to
lose you know this is something where
you you would say well why won't we
teach people how to win
you know why teach them how to lose why
teach them how to heartbreak
why teaching about how to get fired and
how how to handle rejection
because it's part of life it's going to
happen and obviously you cannot teach
people how to lose
without teaching people how to win you
know you don't when you win
you don't put in the other person's face
you say hey listen they really enjoy the
boom you move out there's certain
cultures that you go through certain
criterias of winning and losing that
you're teaching to
the audience students and they're
sitting there saying so you mean to tell
me i'm gonna lose my life bobby you're
gonna have certain times that you're
going to lose now don't get me wrong
the spirit of competition is a very
healthy spirit to have you got to give
your best
there's nothing worse than losing
knowing you could have given better
effort
there's nothing more painful than
knowing you could have beaten your
opponent
but you didn't give your best you were
casual you were not working
you were not developing yourself the
other kids came up and they outwork you
and they took
your victory away from you so if you
lose without giving your best effort
what if we give our best efforts so when
you lose
you know you have nothing to worry about
because you know the amount of hours and
dedication you put into you getting
better at this
you simply lost to a better opponent now
you got to figure out a way to come back
get better so you can beat the opponent
next time you face them
what if school taught these 15 things
what what do you think would happen
if a school started teaching these
things you got four years with a 14 year
old to teach them these things
yes chemistry is needed yes you know yes
your biology is needed i'm not
undermining history or
you know government i'm not undermining
any of that stuff but i'm going to use
all of these 15 things
i'm probably not going to use all of
those classes that are taught in high
school
these i am these will develop leaders
those is just memorization all right got
a memorization cpctc congruent parts of
congruent triangles are congruent
this stuff is going to be tactics and
strategies that will stay here
for the rest of my life having said this
if you watch this video i got another
video i want you to watch it's called
every
university's worst nightmare if you've
not watched it click over here to watch
that
video and if you've not subscribed to
the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody take care
[Music]